fourth news now and a massive law
enforcement bust coordinated by agencies
around the world has led to the seizure
of tons of illegal steroids millions of
counterfeit drugs and the closure of
underground laboratories that produced
performance-enhancing drugs for athletes
the security agency Europol is calling
it the largest series of raids of its
kind it's turned to high use about say a
doping expert who and journalist who's
broken a number of stories of global
reach on the topic of
performance-enhancing drugs good to see
you Ohio
so how widespread was this it was from
my point of view as most widespread
actually which has ever been taken place
by police
police authorities for example Europol
was organizing this on behalf of the
authorities but the world anti-doping
agency was also involved they cooperated
with the authorities so indeed it is
really a really big thing which happened
here but we have also to be honest and
to be clear this is not the first rate
which has been taking place I remember
for example the 2008 Olympics in Beijing
in China at that point also a range of a
similar kind has been taking place as
you mentioned higher the world
anti-doping agency was also involved it
begs the question who were these
performance-enhancing drugs made for not
easy to say but I assume this is more
for recreational sports and not so much
for high performance sports usually most
of the drugs anabolic steroids when the
market are determined are for athletes
which offer example in fitness studios
or bodybuilders or doing kind of kind of
power sports but not in competitions not
so much at least there are always some
which use them also for competitions and
high performance sports but this is more
or less an exception at least that is
the usual experience I have made it
seems that public bodies like the police
on
getting more involved in cleaning up
sport hi what does it look like to you
that shows us that doping controls in
sports
I wouldn't say don't make any sense but
at least they are not very helpful to
understand the whole extent of doping in
sports in general we need investigation
we need police police authorities we
need prosecutors state prosecutors were
dealing with this kind of matters
otherwise we will face another big issue
another problem in the future
we as I told you already in 2008 this
kind of rate has been taken place now we
in 2019 and we see that obviously
there's a big big black market in place
all over the world is doping substances
particularly anabolic steroids so this
raises the questions has been where the
efforts been really been successful in
the past and I have my doubts okay so a
massive global rage European Europol
calling it the largest ever of its kind
but what impact will it have on cheetahs
and global sports higher budget related
will have really much impact because as
I said we have that raids already we had
them in the past we have doping tests a
lot of doping tests we had retest from
the Olympics just have in mind that
there have been a lot of positive tests
retests from the 2008 olympics but these
tests have been analyzed in 2016 or 15
and this didn't help obviously to get
sport clean because people try always to
manipulate in a way that's my feeling
after the old experience I made an as a
journalist on that field ok journalists
and doping expert hi Jose Bolt thank you
thank you